from reincarnation to run-ins with the
mafia and the FBI Steven Seagal has
lived quite the explosive life both on
screen and off
before Steven Seagal became a major star
on the success of Macho action flicks
like Marked for Death and out for
justice he had a bit of an inspirational
life story born in Michigan he moved
with his parents to California where the
frail and asthmatic young Stephen became
obsessed with rock and roll and martial
arts he learned Aikido under the
tutelage of an older man of Japanese
descent then spent some time in Japan
before returning to the U.S to open a
chain of successful dojos his story was
so ready made for Hollywood that the
movie industry had already told versions
of it several of his biographical
details bear a strong albeit
coincidental resemblance to the karate
kid even if Segal's journey to becoming
a warrior was Hollywood fodder it wasn't
necessarily the image he wanted to
project often in interviews he would
foreground his family's roots in
Brooklyn presenting himself as a kid
from The Block who made good but that
particular bubble was burst in a 1990
People magazine profile in which his
mother Pam clarified that his Brooklyn
upbringing was limited to a handful of
of family visits she also noted he was a
puny kid back then
the people profile punctured Segal's
self-promoted image as a New York kid
and took aim at one of his tales about
his pre-hollywood life Seagal claimed
that while living in Osaka in the 1970s
with his first wife yako fujitani he
performed training and Consulting work
for the CIA this bit of unverified
History began circulating in 1988 during
the promotion of his feature debut Above
the Law the film's plot follows Rogue
CIA operatives and Segal claimed a
certain amount of expertise in the field
and even suggested that the script came
from his own experiences as a company
man fujitani couldn't speak about her
husband's clandestine activities during
their 10-year marriage although she did
confirm to people that there were long
stretches of time when he was
unavailable she also noted that while he
could have been guarding the Shah of
Iran or Bishop Desmond Tutu as he
claimed it's just as likely that he was
a poor husband and absentee father in
the early 90s Segal hired retired
intelligence officer Herbert Saunders
for security detail then in 2003 3
Saunders confirmed to the New York Post
that Seagal pressed him to use his CIA
abilities and access to do everything
from stealing files from the drug
enforcement agency to killing someone as
Saunders put it I don't think he's able
to sort out fantasy from fact there are
an awful lot of people who say that
that's not true by the early 80s Segal
was busy with his Aikido dojos in Osaka
Los Angeles and Taos New Mexico the
North Hollywood location quickly became
the Talk of the Town and in 1986 the Los
Angeles Times wrote a glowing story
about Seagal generally taking his bold
claims about his Mastery of Aikido and
Japanese culture at face value the paper
reported that his time in Osaka proved
his medal as a martial artist and his
disdain for imposter karate teachers
Seagal's Dojo attracted film industry
luminaries like James Mason and James
Coburn but his most significant student
was someone less well-known to the
public at large Hollywood super agent
and future Disney President Michael
Ovitz in 1987 Ovitz arranged a martial
arts demonstration for a group of Warner
Brothers Executives while film studios
had been sniffing around Seagal for a
few years Ovitz was the one who finally
made it happen he arranged first of all
to star in Above the Law and helped him
get story and producer credits on the
film as well along with Ovitz other
Hollywood notables shaped Seagal's
career at this early stage including
British actress and model Kelly LeBrock
who had captivated audiences in the 80s
in such films as The Woman in Red and
Weird Science she and Segal met in Tokyo
where she was shooting a fashion
campaign and their relationship gave him
some status that he might not have
enjoyed otherwise the 1986 Los Angeles
Times profile of Segal even included the
claim Kelly LeBrock apparently was his
reward for years of self-denial years of
self-denial is an odd way to describe a
decade of marriage to his first wife
that produced two children but the
profile makes no mention of them in fact
Seagal had been married twice beforehand
in 1984 he married actress Adrian
larussa despite still being legally
married to miyaku fuchitani within a
year larussa annulled their marriage and
by 1986 fujitani divorced him as well as
for LeBrock she and Segal married in
1987 but their Union ended less than
amicably in 1996. over the course of his
career Steven Seagal has done quite a
bit of fight choreography most of the
films he's choreographed are his own but
in the early 80s he worked on the James
Bond film Never Say Never Again training
Sean Connery in martial arts Connery was
already well versed in karate while
preparing for 1967s he only lived twice
he was even awarded an honorary third
degree black belt but for his seventh
outing is Bond he needed to learn a
little Aikido so Seagal taught him how
to throw opponents and manipulate joints
at first the lessons seemed to be going
well but then Connery got a little cocky
so an irritated Seagal allegedly grabbed
his arm and broke the actor's wrist
while Connery was undoubtedly in pain he
reportedly kept training and didn't even
realize the extent of his injury until
years later 15 years ago and it's still
broken yeah I just found out last year
it is Heyday Steven Seagal was the
biggest martial arts star in Hollywood
but that doesn't exactly mean that he
could fight in real life he may be a
Seventh Dawn in Aikido a martial art
that relies on joint locks and the
redirection of momentum but Aikido is
pretty worthless when it comes to
self-defense according to fight analyst
Jack slack Akito famously only works if
the opponent is running straight at you
alas this is something most smart
Fighters never do but nevertheless
Seagal claimed that he could beat anyone
anywhere anytime furthermore he made
some controversial comments about Bruce
Lee Chuck Norris and full contact karate
this didn't sit well with Bob Wall an
actor and high-ranking black belt with
plenty of tournament experience wall was
friends with Norris had worked with Lee
and didn't much care for Seagal's
attitude that was when wall assembled a
group of kickboxing and karate Champions
dubbed The Dirty Dozen some of them
wanted to expose Segal as a fake While
others wanted to avenge some stuntmen
he'd allegedly injured to get his
attention the Dozen appeared in various
magazines but there was ultimately never
any physical Showdown when Segal finally
met wall the movie star reportedly
apologized for what he'd said
Seagal has battled all sorts of bad guys
on the Silver Screen from terrorists to
the Yakuza but he's also faced some
villains in real life including the
mafia in the 90s the actor's partnership
with producer Julius arnazo resulted in
a string of hits alas their relationship
soured in 2000 and things took a dark
turn when the gambino crime family got
involved one day Segal was reportedly
escorted to a Brooklyn restaurant where
he met an alleged Gambino Captain named
Anthony Sonny chiconi according to Segal
chicone ordered him to start working
with naso again and demanded that Segal
Fork over 150 000 for every film he made
evidently Segal was so shaken that he
gave the gangster seven hundred thousand
dollars as he left the meeting someone
supposedly told him if you would have
said the wrong thing they would have
killed you the Scandal came to light in
2003 when the government indicted
alleged crime boss Peter Gotti and 16
others for a host of crimes in addition
to Segal's testimony the government had
recordings of several individuals in
including Tacony And nasso discussing
how they would intimidate Seagal they
even laughed about how they scared the
movie star naso defended himself by
saying Segal had backed out of several
movie deals and owed him five hundred
thousand dollars he was sentenced to one
year in federal prison though he still
suits the golf for 60 million dollars
after nasso got out of jail he settled
with the actor for an undisclosed amount
I still know a thing or two while never
a critical darling Seagal used to pull
in some impressive box office numbers
these days though Seagal's films tend to
go straight to video on demand and he
blames his decline on of all things the
FBI in 2002 Los Angeles Times Reporter
Anita Bush was investigating Segal and
Julius nasso one morning she found a
dead fish a rose and a sign that Reds
stop on her windshield she informed the
FBI who began investigating Segal at
first the feds thought he'd hired a
detective named Anthony pelicano to
intimidate Bush they also suspected
Segal of hiring a thug to scare Vanity
Fair writer Ned Zeman with a gun but
after digging deeper the FBI concluded
that there was no evidence against Segal
instead they focused on pelicano the
private eye who illegally spied on
celebrities the FBI never charged Segal
but they didn't exactly exonerate him
either and he believes all the notoriety
from the pelicano case significantly
harmed his career it may not surprise
you to learn that Steven Seagal is
fascinated with law enforcement he even
served as a cop in Jefferson Parish
Louisiana for about 20 years in 2009 the
actor took things to the next level by
starring in a reality show called Steven
Seagal Lawman in the third season of the
show Seagal moved to Arizona and teamed
up with controversial Sheriff Joe Arpaio
of Maricopa County Arpaio is an Infamous
media Hound so when Segal showed up with
a camera in tow the sheriff decided to
put on a very memorable show in 2011
Arpaio orchestrated a raid against Jesus
Silvera a local man suspected of
cockfighting when the cops arrived they
had more than just a warrant there were
up to 40 SWAT officers a bomb squad
canine units armored vehicles and even
Segal riding on top of a tank during the
raid parts of the suspect's house were
damaged as Seagal's tank tore down the
gates to yovirus property after
arresting guvera segala and Maricopa
officials discovered that yovera owned
over 100 roosters which they decided to
euthanize jovera even claimed that the
police also killed his 11th month old
puppy animal cruelty is one of my
pet peeves guelvera started to file a
lawsuit against the Maricopa County
Sheriff's Office and demanded an apology
letter from Seagal but after pleading
guilty to cockfighting the lawsuit was
dropped as for the raid It ultimately
never aired on TV as someone who's so
famous for breaking bones Steven Seagal
is surprisingly gentle towards animals
he's both a vegetarian and something of
an activist in 1999 Seagal worked to
force South Africa to stop exporting
baby elephants to Japan and received a
pita humanitarian award for his efforts
four years later he wrote to the
government of Thailand to get them to
stop torturing baby elephants he's also
attempted to shame India into treating
cows better but Seagal's favorite
animals of all are of the soothsing
variety during an interview with Peta he
claimed that while he was learning
Aikido in Japan a white dog greeted him
after a few days the canine started
barking apparently telepathically
warning him that his dojo was on fire
Seagal put the fire out and the dog
disappeared never to bark again of
course I'm an animal lover you know
animal lover yeah yeah
Seagal's hands aren't just for busting
up bodies they're also for making sweet
sweet music as he's a longtime musician
who loves himself some blues Seagal has
been playing guitar since age 12 and
he's the front man of the aptly named
Steven Seagal blues band in 2005 he
released his first album entitled songs
from The Crystal Cave overall it's a
straightforward blues record not nearly
as grimy and Soulful as the likes of BB
King or Buddy Guy Sputnik Music wasn't
exactly impressed calling it The Plan 9
from Outer Space of Records in their
review we're inclined to agree with that
take as the track entitled music barely
qualifies as music meanwhile girl it's
all right sounds like the first song
that Jack Johnson threw in the trash and
then there's jealousy a Hungry Ghost
song that could maybe serve as
inspiration for a high school yearbook
quote tune energy drinks boomed in the
mid-2000s with the success of Red Bull
and Monster dozens of competitors
flooded the market and they were often
endorsed by celebrities a certain action
star got in on the game in 2005 with the
release of Steven Seagal's lightning
bolt a ginseng and goji berry powered
drink available in two flavors Cherry
charge and Asian experience Seagal
released a baffling two-minute
commercial featuring himself and
swimsuit models hanging out by a pool
the premise was that he was so enamored
by his own beverage that he wanted to
swim in it it's hard to decide which
element of this ad is more offensive
ingredients with names like Tibetan Goji
and Asian cordyceps the models being
unable to fake any chemistry with Seagal
or the non-descript blues guitar score
reviews of the drink were less than
appetizing though cans are still
available through eBay if you really
want to try them after all these years
lightning bolt tried today
it's electric Russian President Vladimir
Putin has a reputation as a dictator and
human rights violator but Steven Seagal
doesn't exactly see him that way he's
even been quoted as saying I know him
well enough to know that he is one of
the greatest world leaders if not the
greatest world leader alive today the
two met in 2003 at the Moscow film
festival and quickly hit it off probably
thanks to their shared love of martial
arts as Putin is an 8th degree black
belt in Judo soon they were dining
together visiting dojos and promoting
old Soviet exercise programs they even
visited the Russian Judo team during
preparation for the 2012 Olympics in
2015 Putin asked President Barack Obama
to make Segal an honorary console of
Russia but Obama vetoed that idea pretty
quickly despite that Seagal visits
Russia frequently he's even given a keto
demonstrations visited the factory that
produces Kalashnikov rifles attended a
parade on the 70th anniversary of the
Nazis surrendered to the Soviet Union
and played a concert for pro-russian
separatists in the Crimean peninsula
in November 2016 Seagal officially
received a Russian passport and became a
citizen of the country what's more Putin
personally signed the passport and
expressed his hope that the stunt would
promote a normalization of relations
between the United States and Russia but
it appears that this new Russian citizen
is already grinding other countries
gears as it was announced in May 2017
that Segal would be banned from entering
Ukraine for five years according to the
Ukraine's Security Service the ban was
implemented on the basis of Ukrainian
National Security likely due to Segal's
admiration for Russia's aggressive
tactics in the region there was no word
on whether his movies were banned as
well then we have to imagine he's not
winning any popularity contests over
there in 2023 Steven Seagal received the
Russian order of friendship a civilian
honor available to both citizens and
non-citizens of Russia the year prior a
holding company co-owned by Seagal
earned a parcel of land outside Moscow
to build a martial arts center the area
had reportedly been previously set aside
for a Children's Hospital Seagal's cozy
relationship with Putin aside the order
of friendship is no empty gesture
established by a former president Boris
Yeltsin in 1994 the recognition has been
bestowed on dozens of political and
cultural figures past honorees have
included chess master Anatoly karpov
Orchestra conductor Ricardo muchi and
Queen Elizabeth II's cousin Prince
Michael of Kent who gave his medal back
in protest of the war in Ukraine
Canadian politician Adrian Clarkson and
Norwegian politician roona raffleson
have also both returned their orders of
friendship since the start of the war
Russian America should be great allies
and that's the way it should be Steven
Seagal is a man of contrast he's a
high-profile Hollywood Buddhist and
supporter of environmental causes while
simultaneously a champion of strongman
regimes and corresponding paranoid
reactionary politics in 2018 Segal took
his first dip into literary Waters with
the release of his debut book The Way of
the Shadow wolves the Deep State and the
hijacking of America the book was
co-written by Arizona politician Tom
Morrissey and includes a forward by
Sheriff Joe Arpaio the story is a
hodgepodge of trump-era conspiracies
surrounding the Deep State a supposed
group of unelected bureaucrats plotting
against the American people from deep
within the federal government their
master plan is to smuggle Middle Eastern
terrorists through the Mexican border
but standing in their way is tribal
officer and Shameless Segal Avatar John
nantangode he's a mohawk or an Apache
depending on the chapter he's also a
member of The Shadow wolves a real-life
indigenous Patrol unit that works under
the Department of Homeland security
Seagal and Morrissey depict the shadow
wolves as so morally pure and in harmony
with the land that they have nearly
supernatural abilities the mysticism
would be offensive if the writing wasn't
so laughably bad curious minds can still
find the novel available for purchase
but you might be better off reading one
of the book's many bewildered reviews
instead
Steven Seagal is willing to lend his
name and image to some dicey projects
and there's perhaps no riskier example
in his personal history then the
cryptocurrency Bonanza of the late 2010s
and early 2020s in the first quarter of
2018 Segal went to bat for a project
called Bitcoin to gen also known as b2g
he promoted the coin on his social media
pages and allowed his likeness to appear
on official branding without disclosing
that he'd been promised 250 000 in cash
and another 750 000 in b2g tokens for
his endorsement if you're an expert in
white collar crime you'll know that this
is a violation of federal anti-touting
law in 2020 the Securities and Exchange
Commission came down hard on Segal for
his violations issuing fines of 157
thousand dollars in disgorgement and
another 157 thousand dollars in
penalties Segal paid 75 000 towards that
total and then fled to Russia hoping
that his status as a Russian Citizen and
close friendship with Putin would keep
the rest of his money safe however in
2021 a federal judge ruled that the SEC
was still owed the full penalty and
could collect it through Seagal's
business manager as for b2g founder John
Demar faced fraud charges that led to a
five-year prison sentence in January
2023 according to multiple actors that
he's worked with Steven Seagal isn't
exactly the most Pleasant co-star for
example while filming 1996's executive
decision he allegedly shoved John
Leguizamo against a wall caught me off
guard knocked
like
why why
Seagal also made life hard for the
Saturday Night Live cast when he hosted
an episode in April 1991. as Tim Meadows
revealed in the book live from New York
he didn't realize that you can't tell
somebody they're stupid on Wednesday and
then expect them to keep writing for you
on Saturday and according to fellow cast
member Julia Sweeney Seagal wanted to
perform a sketch where he played a
therapist who wants to sleep with a rape
Survivor he was reportedly banned from
ever hosting again Steven said was so
horrible on such a scale it was such a
huge scale of a terrible list in 1996's
the Glimmer Man Stephen tobovsky played
a serial killer who was supposed to be
defeated by Seagal's character but
Seagal had decided that it was bad karma
to keep killing people on screen
toblovsky explained that his character
was trapped in his own private health
and by killing the villain Seagal would
be allowing the bad guy to reincarnate
as a more peaceful being Segal agreed
and the scene went on as scripted
unfortunately Segal later ad-libbed the
line thank God I didn't kill that guy
tobolovsky then had to record a few
lines to make it seem like his obviously
Dead character had somehow survived
however those lines ultimately didn't
make the Final Cut
in 1997 renor rinpochet the Supreme head
of the yingma school of tiben Buddhism
announced that Steven Seagal was a
reincarnated Buddhist Master rinpochet
asserted that in the 17th century Seagal
was turton Chung drag dorje a renowned
translator who opened a monastery and
found several powerful relics thanks to
this supposed spiritual history Segal
was declared Alama which is a venerated
teacher and Ben Buddhism during his
inaugurations Segal pledged to help ease
suffering across the globe and since
then he's given seminars on compassion
at New Age Retreat centers however
several people are skeptical of Segal's
spiritual status since he's been accused
of sexual harassment many have
questioned his moral character others
allege that before he was declared a
Buddhist Master Segal donated quite a
bit of cash to rinpochet's school which
might explain his conveniently glorious
past life it's all especially abnormal
considering that these reincarnated
teachers are are generally discovered as
children
in 2018 emmy-winning actress Juliana
Margulies was a guest on the Katie
Couric podcast the ladies discussed the
metoo movement and markleys recounted a
hotel room meeting she had with Steven
Seagal in the early 90s when a casting
director told her that Segal wanted to
go over a scene with her in his room she
went under the assumption that the
casting director would also attend as
she recalled I walked in and I sat down
and I jumped right back up because there
was something very uncomfortable and
hard in the coach he laughed and said oh
sorry that must have been my gun he
lifted up the cushion and he took out
his gun when Margulies grew nervous
Segal explained oh it's just for all the
crazies that are out there I have to
protect myself Seagal also claimed to be
a Healer and asked to read Markley's
poems he told her that she had weak
kidneys and shortly thereafter she
managed to get out of the room but then
she realized that she hadn't received
the cab fare she'd been promised so she
went back and asked for it she got the
cash as well as the part in out for
justice but she also demanded never to
be alone with Seagal on set the tough
New Yorker in me just inwardly was
laughing because it was so awful and
hilarious
Seagal has faced accusations of sexual
misconduct throughout his career ranging
from harassment to assault even sex
trafficking in one instance images
surfaced of the actor groping his Under
Siege 2 co-star Catherine Heigl who is
only 16 at the time he said you know
Katie I've got girlfriends your age and
I said isn't that illegal and he said
they don't seem to mind and I said Mom
in 1991 actress ran Malone who was
Segal's assistant on out for justice and
three other women accused him of sexual
harassment Warner Brothers ultimately
reportedly paid them fifty thousand
dollars each other incidents have also
made headlines without resulting in any
legal consequences then in 2017 the
metoo movement cast a light on serial
predators in the entertainment industry
suddenly Decades of allegations against
Segal could no longer be overlooked
Portia de Rossi came forward with
Casting Couch horror stories while model
fabiolais and actor Regina Simons
accused Seagal of rape the Los Angeles
County District Attorney's Office
investigated goddess and Simon's claims
in 2018 though no charges resulted in
total more than a dozen women have
reportedly accused Seagal of sex crimes
if you or anyone you know has been a
victim of sexual assault help is
available visit the rape abuse and
incest National Network website or
contact Reigns nationalhelp line at
1-800-656-hope
that's 1-800-656-4673